what do I do I've never played you're
the baby so you have to try and kill
yourself yeah also there's a dildo in
here oh really
oh man look I got a laser pointer shine
it in my eyes like it I can't like Oh
Frick I can't move what the Oh press
Enter Jesus that is annoying
every time I right-click it opens iChat
it's supposed to be something else with
it for some reason that's broken
well is there key bindings that I could
change there's my key bindings but it
does keep shoes give me give me oh you
can give me a gosh-darn second yeah why
is open chat bound a mouse one that's
the stupidest thing okay got it
Oh get back okay now we're good okay
we're good I never knew that I should
have changed the last time I just
figured the game is so broken you
couldn't change anything I don't know I
don't put it past oh there's the dildo
yeah I'm gunning for it it's don't feed
the baby
apparently you is apparently and
apparently smash so how do I kill myself
anyway you want you can get a fork and
stick it in the power outlets you can
get you can drink bleach okay you
smashed a bunny glass childhood I see
see this game came out and everyone was
like demanding that I play it but I was
busy
at the time doing some [__] or some
other stupid eggs you know my stupid
excuses for my life yeah I totally
overlooked it and so I've never seen
anything about it oh I know your
characters freaking out play ball you
could have gotten it and tased me if you
wanted really same with the lot I could
turn on the TV
oh so you can watch me oh watch this
[__] bag shatter this table do I got
throw something at it a few Sprint's
every once in a while something that
every game needs use knife on baby it's
use it come on
welcome to who's your daddy I don't even
know mom should be home by 4:00 okay
you're the dad you know fist me daddy
I'd rather not you know it's okay daddy
mark plyer
I got a gun daddy
oh and I bust your balls right now
you've managed to find a real super
soaker oh no it's not you oh wow what
can I give you well I don't know if I'm
gonna be able to give the baby herpes
because that has a lot of interesting
implications oh wait wait wait
go behind the bed there's a baby grabby
Oh is there where's the baby yeah oh
[__]
there we go what do I do with a baby
grabby
oh you've been a bad boy son I'm gone
I'm Audi Audi that's the most terrifying
baby I've ever seen
would you go in the vent or something no
I won't and in fact I don't want to Lord
oh there's the Taser okay I see it how
do i grab there we go I got a key but I
don't know what it does
I've never known what it does uh-huh no
no it's proud of one of the dollars no
because these doors are locked to me
where'd you go why are the paintings
just freaking out all over why I don't
know everything
okay hang on oh my case is out of juice
apparently like I'd used it apparently
yes are you idiot here I got you a treat
yay bleach dish soap baby yeah my tie
your health is slowly going down but
very slow like that just look straight
up this thing is freaking out
yeah stop that oh wow you do now there
was here's some old raw chicken you can
have that I have a hammer
I think I'm playing this game up early
I'm just helping you
so this is what I've been missing out on
yeah popular mom should be home by 4:00
how can we kill a baby before mom gets
home I don't know prescription meds okay
are we actually teaming up on this one
yeah well that's an option I guess the
more you know oh
tazer no don't taste the baby it's like
a little Shrek baby just is this other
boar freaked out don't eat class kids
yeah that's the only thing that you
should take from this video the only
life lesson also where we would be great
fathers
absolutely together because cept applier
and [__] yeah I so slow even boost can
the baby drowned yeah taze you now look
in the mirror father like son okay baby
it's time for baby's badge drew your
water for you oh god it's not something
up I don't know it's I don't know how to
make you fill up can I eat soap probably
I did you eat the soap oh well done I am
60 no soap you go very funny very
forever I'm just gonna close the door
whatever happens
here happens I think if you feed the
baby fruit what edit out if I saw
somebody say that in the comments lying
to me though your daddy gives you an
apple are you getting better yeah oh my
god you are getting better I just shove
an apple in your face and you're good
what happens you view glass and I just
shove an orange woo toaster that's the
solution okay well I got an emergency
banana that's probably gonna rectify you
you're still dying yeah you lost you
left your toe in me little buddy little
buddy myself with the toaster and let me
plug it in let Daddy plug it in for you
I wanted to die with the toaster the
bathtub are you gonna die from that
soapy eight oh my goodness
way to go what happens when mommy gets
home that just about the baby not my
fault baby your daddy gives you a pill
oh you stopped dying today
yeah you're stuck at 62 I mean you're
still freaking out you've been freaking
out for yes show me freaking out it
shows me seeing a handsome well not
handsome but I'm a oh god that's not
handsome at all I'm hiding come find me
okay alright baby
it's time for your bath oh my run away
from me I think you're gonna win Emma oh
are you I was in the fridge daddy this
is like the random crap you find on
gamejolt but it is kind of a
your baby coming out no okay maybe maybe
I should just let nature take its course
and this pin this one I just provided my
seed it was your mother that birthed you
don't talk about your seed I'll talk
about my seed if I wallet I'm gonna hang
on as a grabber you never know how to
open it no no I'm the key
nobody's Oh where'd you find that key
baby no baby's going in the oven I'm
gonna make a baby kebab oh all right you
get in there you be good be nice your
mom will be home and okay I'm gonna hunt
for ya I'm gonna hunt for here I'll give
you a pill actually when you poison
yourself I'll give you a pill inevitably
you will poison yourself okay
I won't eat batteries until then okay
even though I got a baby all right
steam is annoying dog is they bring it
like affects your microphone it brings
the microphone up and down all the time
really automatically and there's no
option in the audio to change it you've
been pretty consistent for me okay yeah
um can you go that's it now okay I want
to make this a very sensual experience
for me
you're doing yeah totally oh I don't
know I've seen some people like don't
put their severely poisoned everything
in the closet it's like it's like you're
like a strobe light you're just turning
on and off baby's gonna fall down the
stairs
baby do that maybe I have a good time
[Laughter]
[Music]
father good god I mean okay man 99
seconds daddy when you wait that long
for food little [__] this isn't cookie
maybe you should have put it on a stove
numbnuts [__] the stove [__] you in here
with a bucket in batteries oh I read the
cabinet locks no no why would you do
this I ate all the batteries coming
there damn it daddy you're a bad daddy
can I come home now baby can I have a
pill daddy I'm gonna die the pills
either in the bathroom or like pull out
drawers better hurry
things are going purple no no you got
like 40% left I'm feeling woozy I'm
seeing the light at the end oh thanks
pills stop it and then this brings your
health back up huh now you're back to
one more daddy please what about that
cooked meat that seems to be jumping at
all stove down again anyway no no you
gave me the pill so it's cured watch TV
where's my TV why is my TV in [__]
portrait mode [__] sake I swear we're
watching the sideways TV okay cool just
tilt your head
I always feel much more comfortable with
you sorry okay I'll play with my fork
daddy get daddy a beer and play with
your fork okay
I'll go as fast as I can thank God that
baby's gone Jesus now I can watch my
room in peace I think I found the beer
daddy
you can't find the beer just cover the
corpse with a painting it's okay forget
it ever happened
oh I can smack it around my face Oh God
[Laughter]
don't you wanna know what this is no
mommy still don't use on daddy
the shape is ideal for massaging the
prostate someday well let me let me play
you the video tapes me and mommy puts
Baby in the corner
that's what the baby's trying to kill
itself to do now I think we're I think
we're out yeah okay then
who says bye
[Music]
yeah welcome back everybody I just I had
to record this because it's a slow orbit
on the baby just in the middle of his
toys like I mean I'm in a totally
innocuous location your daddy has
abandoned you he's sick here [__]